we are here with buzzfeed to share
our pentagon hot text and see how
similar they are
to yours
which is the best 21 single i think run
away
because the title is english
i think i think shine shine recently
reached 200 million views
[Applause]
[Music]
english words incorrect in the course
which pentagon music video is the most
loved i think what's clear
it's cool it's cool
[Music]
that was fresh which concept goes
pentagon full of the best
romantic oh yeah because you have
romantic voice right because i am a
romantic guy oh yeah
i think cute concept oh why because
you're cute
no no our soul soul is cute
especially especially yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's so cute yeah yeah what concept
do you pull off
the most
[Applause]
[Applause]
which comeback was the most stylish
i think genius a genius yeah why
i like that tim tim
[Applause]
positive it was an
obvious yeah result yeah which pop icon
should depend upon collaborate
with three it's so hard to use i would
like
ariana grande oh i like
english oh i think it will be great
to collaborate with lady gaga
because because she she's the she's the
most
conceptual yeah yeah singer
in america yeah yeah we're the most
conceptual idol in kpop
bielsen yeah it's the best
so i want to collaborate with beyonce
[Applause]
she's the brand new icon yeah yeah which
means song has the most iconic
choreography
oh
[Music]
i come back to 7 years old oh
good english oh that's a very emotional
song
oh i think it's brilliant spring storm
[Applause]
we all have same beautiful memory about
moonshine
uh choreography yeah with american fans
all over the world yeah yeah finally
which pentagon airborne
is the crown jewel in their
discography ah wow i think demo
version because that that album was the
first start
as we started to write our write our own
songs but i think positive yeah is our
crown because chinese chinese our
best most popular popular song universe
[Applause]
thank you buzzfeed well as you guys all
know we
released our new album with and you can
see us
online on our music program with daisy
so thank you for watching us
[Applause]
goodbye
you